if you were trapped in a virtual reality
death game where one wrong move in game
will kill you in real life what would
you do you're gonna have to clear 100
Levels if you want to free yourself from
this beautiful prison I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the virtual death
game in Sword Art online because Kirito
here is an above 5'7 Warrior chick that
sits inside and plays death games all
day no no no that's why you're better
off going outside and getting a fresh
healthy round of Rage Shadow Legends
this free to play game on IOS and
Android and PC will cast you as one of
the many long dead talarian Warriors to
be resurrected by talaria's Immortal
Guardian the Arbiter to stop the dark
lord siroth in the East so join millions
of players to battle alongside with you
or take on real life players in PvP
battles in the arena with over 650
completely unique Champions to collect
from different factions because unlike
Sao this game will treat you to the
hottest battles that won't cost you your
life and these guys have just released a
special buff blonde-haired MMA and pro
wrestling Legend character for you to
play as Ronda Rousey Rousey and battling
as Ronda Rousey means that you'll be
able to experience her crazy in-game
backstory with her character taking some
inspiration from her background in
Combat Sports because this Warrior
fights with her bare fists trained since
birth alongside her several brothers and
eventually becoming the queen of the
Arena use the special promo code raid
Rhonda to get a bunch of cool [ __ ] for
leveling up your
Ray's got a bunch of huge new updates
with a ton of features from new
Champions being added to the mix as well
as some really cool holiday looking
champions for those looking to get into
the festive Spirit and the bastions even
been decorated to look all wintry too oh
so nice and raids even added a brand new
dungeon and the introduction to the
artifact Ascension so Ascend to
Greatness for you Amazon Prime members
out there because you especially will be
able to get exclusive Awards in raid
right now and new players can use my
link or scan the QR code right here to
get a free starter pack worth almost 30
dollars and a free champion verges and
also this really cool in-game loot so
put on your blonde with your all
feminine walls and your Japanese
Schoolboy attitude and get to gaming
thank you rage Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video now back to the
show Kirito is your average kid and beta
tester for a virtual reality game on the
day of the game's official launch his
sister leaves the house and he enters
the game along with everyone else into
the virtual world of Sword Art Online
everyone is excited as hell as they
slowly explore the area however this guy
notices Kirito walking around like he's
been here before he catches up to him
and introduces himself as Klein and
finds out that Kirito was a beta tester
for the game Klein bakes Kirito to teach
him his ways and Kirito spends the next
few hours teaching him how to play the
game Klein then tells him that he has to
leave the game for a bit to eat dinner
and that he'll hop back online right
after but that's when he realizes that
his dream game is about to turn into his
worst nightmare Klein weirded out tells
Kirito that there's no option to exit
the game and that's when Kirito realizes
that he can escape the game either with
no way to log out there are trapped
inside this virtual reality World Klein
begins to freak out but Kirito tells him
to chill out and that this must just be
a glitch within the game but he doesn't
realize that the truth could not be more
horrifying suddenly they hear bells
ringing in the distance and everyone is
teleported back to the center of town
and the game master shows up to tell all
of them something shocking he tells all
the players that their Virtual Reality
helmets are working just fine and that
their minds are now locked inside of
this world that it's a feature of this
game and if they die even once in game
they'll be dead in real life and if
anyone tries to take off their helmets
in the outside world this will cause the
safety feature of their helmets to
instantly turn off and Fry the brain of
the player inside killing them for good
that unfortunately over 200 players
families have tried to remove the player
from the game and all the players died
with no way out the game master tells
the players that the only way to survive
and to log out will be to clear all 100
Floors of the game and to do this
they'll need to defeat the main
terrifying bosses on every floor first
everyone's avatars then begin to change
into the player's real identities and
everyone here realizes that this isn't a
joke if they don't win the game they'll
be stuck inside this virtual reality
death game forever and soon thousands of
them will die trying to escape this hell
hole no no no shoot this is horrifying
because these guys have just entered a
virtual reality game set within a world
known as aincrad and given that this
game's official launch day had over 10
000 people annoyingly sign up to
participate in this death game is insane
this is just like the Matrix and now
somebody has to become Neo we've now
become stuck in this matrix-like
hellhole with no escape the VR headsets
that these fools are wearing contain a
safety switch that if anyone tries to
take off their helmet it will emit a
powerful microwave signal that will
shoot right through their brain killing
them instantly and if this is similar to
microwave signals in real life then that
means that these helmets are capable of
transmitting frequency radio signals
similar to weapons known as directed
energy weapon while this helmet might
not be capable of producing the same
amount of power as a full-on laser death
beam the simple effect of emitting a
radio frequency signal while housing the
player's brain inside of their helmet
means that their brain will likely be
overwhelmed by the simultaneous
activation of countless nerves resulting
in the player going unconscious at first
but since the game master said that the
microwave signal will kill the player
instantly it's likely that the radio
signal that's going to be emitted will
be put out at a lower frequency as a
higher frequency will likely not be
enough to penetrate the skull and reach
the brain itself and that means that
once the radio signal starts to emit
essentially the player's head will be
cooked inside of their very own
microwave helmet frying the Brain before
exploding your mostly water-filled
eyeballs and rupturing every cell nerve
ending in your face and skin but this
all does happen within a split second
meaning you probably wouldn't feel a
thing maybe people begin to panic left
and right and everyone freaks the hell
out Kirito then quickly drags Klein into
this alley and tells him that in order
to escape they'll need to First upgrade
all of their weaponry and become as
strong as possible if they want to
survive but Klein tells Kirito that he
has friends in the game that he needs to
go help first they then agree to part
ways for now and go on their separate
Journeys one month late all the players
hold a meeting because everything has
gone terribly wrong no one since the
game has begun has been able to clear
the first floor and over 2 000 players
have already died but this blue-haired
guy says that his Guild has finally
managed to discover the location of the
first floor boss if they kill the boss
they'll manage to make it on to the
second floor everyone then teams up and
Kirito then Partners up with this
mysterious girl Asuna blue-haired guy
then takes out a guidebook of the game
detailing all of its enemies he says
that this book was written and left
behind by an ex-beta tester as a sign of
Good Will hint hint he then reads the
guidebook out loud and goes over the
enemy boss its powers and what Horrors
they should expect the next day the raid
group sets out to the boss's Lane
entering through this dark door and they
discover the most terrifying enemy yet
the battle begins as blue haired guy
leads his Squad to take out all of the
men minions the corner the boss but
blue-haired guy gets too cocky and
decides to face this monster by himself
and that was his biggest mistake
suddenly all the players see the boss
monster reveal a different weapon than
the one that was detailed in the player
guide book shock and Terror rolls across
Kirito's face and he yells out to
everyone to retreat but it's too late
the boss monster nearly kills blue
haired guy and sends him flying back
before he dies he reveals to Kirito that
he was also a beta tester too and
declines to be saved wanting Revenge
Kirito leads the rest of the team to try
on a new tactic against his boss and
they managed to defeat him once and for
all what this was supposed to be an easy
win this was supposed to be an easy
thing to do and now it's turned out to
be a gruesome bloodbath and the
terrifying thing is that these guys were
super naive to assume that everything
detailed within this player guidebook
was 100 accurate now I get it not
everyone would believe that the
guidebook is 100 accurate but really
they should have been more cautious they
got too confident that everything was
going exactly as the guidebook said they
should have held back some and because
of this many of them died if the
guidebook in the first place was solely
written based on the beta testers
experience in the game in beta then they
should have accounted for a percentage
of human error in the recordings and
they should have also assumed that not
everything written in the player
guidebook would have been 100 accurate
to begin with and to State the obvious
things can change from a beta to the
final version of the game the problem
here is that the monster didn't take out
the weapon that Kirito expected but a
different weapon and the weapon that the
boss used to slaughter these players was
different than the one that he used in
the beta game and this has huge
implications because that means that all
the intricacies of the game that they
could have expected now have the
possibility of being different which is
kind of a duh thing to think about
really if you really think about it the
game creator just literally announced
that this thing has now turned into a
real-life death game meaning Kirito and
everyone here going forward needs to
expect the unexpected because they were
woefully ignorant from the get-go
blue-haired guy got way too cocky and
sealed his fate when when he decided to
not use his boy band Entourage to help
him out or use them as a meat Shield
because they were literally standing
right behind him and because of that
literally blue-haired guy deserves
whatever VR hell this game sent him to
the group begins cheering for a job well
done but this guy was watching Kirito
during the battle and blames Kirito for
blue-haired guy's death and says that he
must be an ex-beta tester since he
didn't act like the rest of them he knew
how to defeat the boss and didn't tell
the group beforehand about the special
weapon that he had he is responsible for
the deaths of everyone here Kirito then
begins to laugh and reveals that Not
only was he an ex-beta tester but he was
the only one in the beta who managed to
clear all 100 levels and beat the game
the group is horrified at how much
Kirito knows and calls him an outright
cheater but Kirito then says that he
doesn't cheat games he beats them he
then tells everyone that he's the top G
around here and leaves some months later
Kirito gets convinced to join a guild
called the black cats and despite being
a solo player and being racked with
Incredible emotional guilt he accepts
their offer not realizing that everyone
he teams up with here will be brutally
murdered before the week's end the next
day he gets word that this girl member
of their team named Sachi has gone
missing he goes to find her and
discovers that she has nearly lost the
will to survive and thinks that escaping
this game is impossible but Kirito then
reassures her little self that their
Guild is strong enough to beat the game
and that they'll all be able to escape
the game together soon this kid has no
idea how horrifyingly wrong he is the
next day The Guild decides to head to
one of the more dangerous higher floors
as hunting on these higher levels will
give them more valuable points however
Kirito thinks they're not ready but this
guy manages to convince him that they
can handle it they reach the higher
floors and enter this hidden room and
they discover a treasure chest this guy
gets excited and he tries to open it but
they suddenly realize that it's a trap
the group begins to panic as they get
surrounded by enemies and realize that
they can't use their teleportation Chris
crystals to escape suddenly everyone
except Kirito here begins to realize
that they're about to die these kids bit
off way more than they could ever chew
and now they're about to be brutally
fudged up they've gone to floor 27 of
Minecraft which is a floor of Perpetual
Darkness with very few openings in the
exterior of the floor meaning this floor
is generally constantly covered in
darkness and that means from the look of
the floor I could have told you that
this level was scary as balls however I
do get it this floor is loaded with
precious goodies and treasures that they
could have used to help them level up
and get better at the game which
explains why the group wanted to try
this floor out but the stupid thing is
that these group of players
underestimated the horse that they were
about to face and except for Kirito here
all the members knew each other from the
outside world and they were all members
of the school computer Club this means
that Kirito here should have known that
the snotty knows little Bratz Ambitions
were bigger than their fighting
capabilities he should have revealed and
told them up front that he was way
stronger than they all were bind and
that they were clearly overestimating
their abilities when it came to what
levels they could actually take on but
since Kirito here is determined to win
the game at all costs then he should
have been fully committed and been
thinking less with his heart and more
with his evilness because his group
looks like a lot of beautiful Shields of
meat that he could have used because in
the run-up to this Mission Kirito got to
know all of these kids and could have
used this knowledge to get to know them
even more and use it to his Advantage
the fact is that these people were all
friends from the outside world so it
makes sense that their loyalties between
them would be stronger than the norm but
Kirito could have used this now again
when it comes to getting the treasure
we're all about it but care to upon
first chance of seeing that treasure
should have ordered one of the kids to
enter the room while the rest of them
hang outside and on the off chance that
it was a trap whoops the group has now
lost only one member and they all could
be super sad for one anime second to
then move on with their day and then the
rest of the group could have avoided
playing that level entirely or the worst
case before this door closed do to the
player's loyalty to each other the other
players would have likely tried to rush
inside of the room to Aid the trapped
victim which would have made a perfect
time for Kirito to simply walk away and
let them deal with the situation
themselves because anyone with a guild
name like the moon lit black cats
deserved to have the [ __ ] beat out of
them and get killed in the process
that's what I think the gang tries to
fight off the enemies but they aren't
strong enough and Kirito is then forced
to watch his entire guild die right in
front of him one by one and he barely
manages to escape himself months later a
very depressed Kirito then learns of a
rare item that brings dead players back
to life thinking he can finally revive
Sachi but not the others he sets out to
find it like the simp that he is he goes
through this portal and he runs into
Klein's group and discovers that they've
been following him scared for his friend
Klein tells Kirito to join his Guild
because it's too dangerous to be a solo
player these days but that's when they
get surrounded by a military Guild Klein
offers to hold off these guys as Kirito
heads through this portal to find and
defeat the boss solo he quickly wins and
returns to Klein's Group which is still
standing and he hands him the Revival
item he tells Klein that this Relic can
only revive players within 10 seconds
from their death meaning it's useless to
him and it's too late for Kirito to
revive any of his old Guild members
later that night Kirito receives an old
voice note of Sachi recorded before her
death telling him how grateful she was
to have met him and to not blame himself
for anything that might happen to her
and Kirito Mourns her death even harder
more time passes in-game as Kirito
levels up in every way possible and one
day even spots a familiar face Asuna
while he's relaxing out in the sun
during his day off he finds out that
she's risen through the ranks of her own
guilt and she gives him [ __ ] for napping
at a time like this but Kirito tells her
to chill out and relax and she
reluctantly joins him but accidentally
falls asleep later she wakes up to find
Kirito watching over annoyed at herself
and knowing that anyone could have
killed her while she slept she thanks
Kirito for watching over her and offers
to pay him back with a meal and over the
coming weeks Kirito and Asana spent more
and more time together and even solve a
murder mystery that really isn't
relevant to the main storyline but after
that Asuna takes a liking to Kirito and
asks him to become her friend having no
idea that this friendship will cost him
her life the next morning Kirito walks
into pink hair girl's blacksmith shop
and asks if she has a sword for herself
that is as good or better than his
current weapon named the elucidator she
proudly shows off her latest weapon and
Kirito tries it out but breaks it pink
hair girl gets mad at Kirito and tells
him that if he can bring her the
materials for it she'll be able to make
him the strongest sword he's ever seen
and she demands to tag along with Kirito
before he sets off and he reluctantly
agrees guiding him to floor 55 Kirito
warns her of the horrifying monster
they'll soon encounter and that they'll
need to beat this terrifying beast in
order to collect the materials to make
his sword finally reaching the dragon's
leg Kirito quickly tells pink hair girl
to hide and to not come out no matter
what because he thinks she's not ready
for the monster that is about to show up
Suddenly they hear a rumbling Roar and
come face to face with a horrifying
Dragon here to toko's Toe to Toe with
the beast but after a few moments pink
hair girl thinks the battle is over and
comes out of hiding shocking Kirito as
the dragon then sends an
earth-shattering wind strike down on her
and both of them get set down into this
pit now stuck in this steep hole and
unable to use their teleportation
Crystal to escape they're trapped and
they think of their next move okay this
is insane because what these kids have
found themselves up against was the
floor 55's boss known as the White Worm
a dragon capable of producing a rare
mineral inside of its body so when it
has to go drop a Lincoln Log it
basically poops out a rare material that
can be used by blacksmiths to create
some sweet swords this is why pink hair
girl and Kirito are here pink hair grow
clearly underestimated this dragon's
capabilities because the truth is that
this creature could not be more
horrifying because as we've just seen
this monster is capable of using its
claws firing attacks a freezing breath
and a blizzard attack among many other
things the fact is is that Kirito
correctly assumed that judging from pink
hair girl's demeanor and overall Persona
yeah she was a major liability to bring
along and she did nothing but gave
Kirito more responsibilities to look
after and she didn't even have the
decency to shut her big mouth and listen
to Kirito's orders however he needs her
as obtaining the crystal is only
possible with a master blacksmith
present in a party therefore Kirito my
good man I would have suggested that you
think long term and should have brought
along a third unsuspecting member for
the trip as much as pink hair girl is an
annoying liability her skill makes her
invaluable at the moment but bringing
along a third member along with him
could have meant that Kirito could have
used this person as a distraction for
the dragon and use him or her as a shoot
of meat when the time came Kirito could
have easily promised part of the
dragon's Crystal to the third member
from beforehand as promised payment but
of course this third party member would
have never reached that stage as he
would have been dead before that ever
happened in fact here if he wanted to be
super up front he could have advertised
a dragon hunting party to the commoners
and each floor's adventuring Guild and
could have easily recruited four to five
people to his Hunting Party with the
promise that each person would get a
portion of the crystal harvested from
the dragon there would have been plenty
to go around I mean if you look from
here there was a lot of rare important
Dragon [ __ ] this would have given Kirito
more than enough Shields of me to use
and distract the dragon when the time
came for it since it likely would have
at some point flown down to the surface
to take a bite out of these people and
that is when Kirito could have attacked
it at a closer range and in case you
haven't noticed Kirito is way stronger
than any of these players so even if
some of the players within his Dragon
party were to survive the whole dragon
attack Kirito could have simply killed
with these lower level players after
killing the dragon this way ensuring
that no news of player murder would ever
reach back down to the other floors and
the fact is that he is in an isolated
area and that means despite his player
cursor turning orange after committing
murder this would only be temporary and
would go back to green in no time
meaning he could have just waited it out
on floor 55 until the coast and his
player cursor was clear and let's not
forget pink hair girl I mean Kirito
could have simply threatened to kill her
until she made his sword and then could
have killed her anyways afterwards but
then again pink her girl is friends with
Asuna so that's probably a bad life
scratch that out of options for now the
two decide to make camp for the night
the next morning pink hair girl sees
Kirito digging and he discovers the
special dragon's metal that they were
looking for but they quickly realized
that there is an awful lot of these
things around here they quickly realize
that this isn't just a hole this is the
Dragon's Nest and the two hit a ride on
the dragon that suddenly comes down to
greet them later back at Town pink hair
Girl Crafts Kirito's new badass weapon
he offers to pay her but she says that
all she wants is to be Kirito's
exclusive personal blacksmith from now
on Kirito agrees and now with a new
weapon and some new help he prepares to
take on more of the game's terrifying
levels two years go by and more and more
deaths have occurred and the players of
Sword Art Online have begun to grow
desperate but some players have even
begun to give up stating that the world
they live in is just as good as the real
one Kirito still a solo player continues
to try and defeat the game's higher
levels and one day he spots and catches
a rare rabbit in the woods killing it he
brings it back to town and bumps into
Asana the only one in town who has
leveled up all of her cooking points and
the only one who can actually make the
bland food in the world they live in
taste good she offers to cook it up for
Kirito so long as she gets half of the
meal but little does Kirito know that
Asuna has other intentions at dinner she
pretty much forces Kirito to stop
playing solo and to join her into
becoming a party of two Kirito knowing
the horrors of what happened to his
first party reluctantly agrees and that
was a big mistake the next morning the
two meet up and prepare to take on
another level but suddenly asuna's
Bodyguard from her Guild shows up turns
out he's been secretly following her The
Bodyguard known as creepy face demands
that Asuna come back to the guild with
him but Kirito stops him and challenges
him to a duel stating that Asuna can go
with whoever she wants the battle occurs
but however it's over in a matter of
seconds Kirito easily defeats creepy
face and sends him home packing but he
unknowingly made a new enemy that will
soon try to kill him Kirito and Asuna
eventually reach floor 74 and battle
their way through the level with Asuna
being way more capable than any of
Kirito's old teammates they finally
reached the boss room and Kirito says
that they should be safe if they only
take a small peek into the room writing
their teleportation crystals in case
[ __ ] goes south they open the doors but
that's when they come across the most
horrifying Beast a Minotaur the two
Retreat just outside and try to plan
their Battle Tactics however they
suddenly spot Klein and his party and
they are stunned to find Kirito in a
party with a girl just then they're
joined by the Army a guild that operates
on the first floor and they aggressively
demand that Kirito hand over all of his
map data since he's the player that's
cleared the most floors forcing Kirito
to give it to them however something is
off and Kirito notices that all of these
troops are exhausted and Kirito warns
the leader of the troops that his men
aren't ready for the boss that awaits
them in this room but the leader tells
him to shut his face and the Army leader
orders his men to fight the boss
triggering the start of a most beautiful
Bloodshed suddenly Kirito and Asuna hear
beautiful screams roaring from the
boss's room and the group starts to
investigate seeing the Bloodshed the
monitor has killed nearly all the
soldiers and Kirito discovers that they
can't use their teleportation crystals
in this room Asuna and Kirito quickly
realized that unless they help these
people they'll all be brutally murdered
okay this is insane because what this
group are up against is the boss of the
74th floor known as The Gleam Eyes but
this demon is much more capable than
this group thinks which makes this boss
really scary this demon is capable of
firing purple energy spheres from its
mouth and uses both its swords and fists
to fight but the terrifying Factor about
this Beast is its combat skills Kirito
here was forced to help the military
even though he he warned them before
[ __ ] went South however because he
essentially was forced to help them out
means that he failed to plan his tactics
he had to improvise due to the military
sudden involvement it's noted that the
Minotaur is situated within the boss's
room and the fact that these two were
able to exit the boss room shortly after
discovering him makes it plausible to
assume that any one of these people
could have escaped the boss room to the
other side of this barrier for a quick
breather and to be protected from any
attacks since it's likely that this
creature can't cross the boundaries into
the safe Zone this means that instead of
going in balls to the walls Kirito and
Asuna could have waited on their balls
before going into the ring they should
have worked on bringing the soldiers
back outside of the room into the safe
Zone first before going back in to fight
the Minotaur Kirito essentially could
have used this time on the safe side of
the boundary to plan his next move of
attack without having the useless
soldiers being an unnecessary
distraction and could have turned them
from being useless into useful or better
yet he could have gone after this boss
the old-fashioned how to beat wearing
could have used all all these soldiers
including Asana who we know is
practically in love with him as
beautiful Shields are made to distract
the monster with while we work on taking
him out and I know that some of y'all
will get upset at the thought of Kirito
using Asuna as a shield of meat but
let's be honest Kirito here is your
average kid gamer and Asuna here is a
girl which means he never had a real
shot with her anyways the group fights
the boss but they realize it's much
tougher than anything they've ever faced
and Kirito realizes that he has to use a
unique skill that only he has and he
summons his special skill dual wielding
swords and he unleashes a barrage of
attacks this is the reason the Kirito
has never used a shield before and he
brutally destroys this boss once and for
all later news of Asuna and Kirito's
Victory spreads throughout the game and
the two are finally summoned by the
leader of asuna's Guild on floor 55
Commander stud face the leader of the
Knights of the Blood Oath he gets mad at
Kirito for allowing Asuna to become
distracted and he thinks he's trying to
slowly steal her away as she's one of
their best members Kirito defies the
commander and tells him to eat [ __ ] but
Commander stud face says that the only
way to really steal Asuna and take her
away from the Knights of the Blood Oath
will be to duel with him one on one
Kirito then agrees and the duel is
marked down but that was his biggest
mistake the day of the battle rolls
around and Kirito gets ready for what he
thinks will be an easy win the battle
starts and he attacks Commander stud
face with dual blades but is surprised
by Commander stud Face's defense he
attempts a final at what should be a
certified kill on him but suddenly time
slows down and Kirito's attack fails and
Commander stud face lands the final blow
on him lose Kirito is stunned but now
forced to join asuna's killed later he
is then summoned for basic training but
that's when he discovers that his
teachers for the day will be none other
than creepy face and no soul Ginger hair
guy heading deep into this dark Valley
the group stops for a lunch break
however that's when Kirito notices that
one of his teachers collapsed and he
realizes that they've all just been
Paralyzed by creepy face reveals that
he's actually part of the murder Guild
The Laughing Black Coffins Kirito is
then forced to watch his creepy face
brutally tries to take the soul of no
soul Ginger hair guy murdering him in
front of Kirito's eyes okay I mean you
kind of asked for this one Kirito really
you really did how could kyota have
never expected to be screwed over by a
dude that he embarrassed in front of his
babe earlier in reality he should have
assumed that judging by a creepy Face's
creepy face this guy obviously was
giving off Colossus guy energy which
means from the get-go Kirito should
never have blindly accepted food
supplied by him but this does beg the
question how did the guild the Knights
of the Blood Oath let this murderous
psychopath slip past them are they
really that desperate because he was
already a part of another guild The
Laughing coffins and unfortunately
Infamous player Guild within the game
that exists solely to kill other players
within the game and paralyzation is a
common method that this death Guild uses
on their victims before they brutally
torture them to death you kind of think
the Knights of the Blood Oath would have
some sort of back Crown check on their
people also because Sword Art Online
mimics real life Flora to an extent it's
safe to say that these two were
Paralyzed by some sort of tetrododoxin
an extremely potent poison most commonly
found in marine animals which works by
interfering with the transmission
signals from the nerves to the muscles
leading to paralysis of the muscles and
the body the fact that something like
tetrododoxin is the likeliest option is
due to the geography of where the
Knights of the Blood Oath are stationed
floor 55 a floor notable for its diverse
flora and fauna with mountains Hilly
Fields snow deserts that are all spread
out throughout this floor this makes the
likelihood that creepy face could have
gotten access to this poison through the
fish more likely than not Kirito was way
too Carefree with his attitude towards
creepy face we all know Kirito is
overpowered but he was overpowered to
the point of being stupid he shouldn't
have trusted him as fast as he did
especially when the dude literally
looked like the creepiest piece of [ __ ]
anybody has ever seen the riding was
already on the wall for this one this is
why if you ever duel in front of a girl
and win you better finish the job and
put the loser out of his misery then in
their creepy face prepares to kill
Kirito when suddenly Asuna shows up out
of nowhere to save him having secretly
followed them she gets creepy face down
on his knees and thinks he's surrendered
but just then creepy face grabs a nearby
sword and is about to murder her when
Kirito manages to save her killing
creepy face once and for all and losing
his left hand in the process the two
then hug it out and Kirito then asks
Asana if he can stay at her place for
the night stunned by his boldness she
says yes and Asuna thanks Kirito for
saving her with another meal and then
the two have a hobo hobo hobo of a good
time if you know what I mean Asuna then
proposes that they take a break from the
front lines for a bit but Kirito one up
siren suggests that they get married
Weeks Later the two adjust to living a
quiet life down in one of the more
peaceful floors and they are wandering
around this Forest when they spot a
little girl in the distance and they
think she may be lost from her parents
but something is off and they realize
that the little girl has no in-game
cursor above her head unlike all the
other players in the game suspicious
they take her back back to their house
to look after her and later discovered
that her name is yui and she has no
memory of where she came from and why
she was alone in the forest with more
questions than answers they decide to
cut their honeymoon short and take this
little girl back down to the first floor
to look for her parents back down to the
level where this nightmare first started
heading down to the first floor they run
into the army extorting a group of
children and then Asana shows them whose
boss but suddenly the little girl starts
reaching for the sky and she mutters the
phrase everyone's Hearts suddenly a loud
hissing White Noise erupts through the
world and the little girl face they take
yui to the local orphanage that looks
after all the kids in the game suddenly
the Army's second in command enters the
orphanage silver hair lady she thanks
them for putting the Army in their place
earlier and asks them for their help
revealing to them that over the years
the Army Guild has become corrupt as
hell and has started sending members to
their deaths on higher floors the
massacre they witnessed with the Army on
floor 74 was all because of a rogue
general and this same general has now
lured her second in command deep under
this town's basement to die silver hair
lady begs these two for their help to
save her friend and they agree but yui
insists on joining them as well the
group heads deep underground and
discovers silver-haired lady Sprint
still alive and trapped within a safe
Zone as he calls out for them she runs
to him through the corridor when all of
a sudden Kirito realizes that this is a
horrifying trap he saved silver hair
lady from getting brutally murdered as
they stand off against a new enemy boss
whose level is too high for them to see
and they prepare for battle once again
okay this is terrifying because the fact
is that this group is up against an
enemy whose level is so dang high they
can't even see it this means that they
have no shot against this creature and
this means that it's likely just as
strong as the bosses on floor 90 and
above the Fatal Scythe is an extremely
powerful boss and is able to kill anyone
with just one Blow from its Scythe if it
does it right and prefers to attack from
the Shadows which explains how he tried
to attack silver-haired lady from the
shadows as she was running now while in
reality they can't do much at this point
unless they pull off some deus ex
machina type of thing wink wink Kirito
and Asana should have used silver-haired
lady because she was the one asking them
for help and they should have used her
as an opportunity to strengthen Guild
relations between Knights of the Blood
Oath and the military hear me out now
Asuna is way up there on the totem pole
in terms of her position within the
Knights of the Blood Oath Guild which
means instead of the two of them going
down to help silver-haired girl like the
two Knuckleheads that they were Asuna
due to her power and position in the
guild should have asked her Guild's help
on this matter also silver-haired lady
is no grunt she's actually the second in
command of the military which means that
it is very likely that she too could
have ordered or convinced her own guilt
to join forces with the Knights of the
Blood Oath in Saving this one member and
with both forces teaming up this would
have strengthened the relations between
the military Guild that silver-haired
the lady belonged to and the Knights of
the Blood Oath which overall would have
improved all of the players chances of
getting out of this hellhole alive due
to the fact that everyone's better
working together I know I rarely say
that but in this case it's true the Gang
realizes that there is no way to beat
this boss until yui steps in front of
them and Kirito realizes that she's not
just an NPC she's an immortal object and
she destroys the boss with a single
fatal blow yui's memories are then
finally restored and she explains to the
two how the game's system is run by the
Cardinal program and that she was a
feature of the game that was meant to
Aid the player's mental state throughout
however when Sword Art Online officially
launched two years ago the program
banned her from interacting with anyone
and she was forced to watch everyone
lose their minds she then explains that
Kirito and Asuna were the first people
that she saw who fell joy since the game
began and so she set out to find them
however using her program to save Kirito
and Asuna just now means that the
Cardinal program knows where she is and
begins to erase her from the game
effectively killing her Kirito quickly
uses the nearby computer to digitally
save yui's Soul inside of this in-game
item later the two receive a message
from Commander stud face telling them to
return to the front lines for one of the
most important battles they'll ever face
but they have no idea that this will be
the final battle that they ever do
Commander stud face informs them that he
needs every Soldier available to save a
20-man team that recently has
disappeared down in a boss's Lair and
the two agree to help him the next day
everyone gathers to join the fight even
Kirito's old friend Klein and bald guy
they head down into the dungeon but
discovered that the room is empty but
Kirito knows that this isn't all there
is and he readies his sword suddenly the
horrifying boss drops from the ceiling
it's a skull Reaper it annihilates
dozens of players instantly one shot
killing everyone nearby it's a
horrifying bloodbath but Kirito and
Asana figure out a way to fight the
monster together and they turn the tide
and helped lead the troops to Victory
the group beats the skull Reaper but
dozens of men have died and suddenly
Kirito notices Commander stud Face's
Health hasn't gone down one bit and he
thinks it's mighty sus he attacks him
and then discovers that he's an immortal
object and everyone here finds out that
Commander stud face is actually the
creator of sore Art online and he is the
final boss of this game suddenly he
paralyzes everyone around him and
challenges Kirito to a Final Duel if he
wins he'll beat the game and everyone
here will go free okay this is insane
because up until now we already knew
Commander stud face was overpowered as
hell but the fact is is that this guy is
simply the Avatar of the game's Creator
and that means that Kirito and this gang
is royally screwed this guy no doubt has
all the top tier perks of this game and
even though he just offered to fight
Kirito with all of his extra skills
turned off his knowledge and expertise
of the game in and of itself makes this
match uneven as hell and also there's no
way that this guy's gonna play fair the
mind we're fighting is the creator of
this game that we're in for someone to
create such a world takes determination
skill and a fortitude to want to achieve
his object at all costs because to
achieve building this world means that
he knowingly created this game with the
knowledge that thousands of people would
die and means that to achieve this goal
it's likely that he would have only been
able to get there by not feeling any
remorse or guilt about his actions and
sent sensing thousands of people to
their death you could have had some sort
of empathy disorder well this doesn't
mean that this dude is a bona fide
psychopath just yet this does mean that
this guy is one psych evil away from
being declared a complete sociopath it
means that coupled with his knowledge of
the game means that Kirito can't afford
to think that this fight is a fair one
oh no no no no no it's not even if
Commander stud face disables all of his
powers to fight him this fight will
never be fair kyotito accepts the duel
and the two battle it out however Kirito
is powerless against this God and is
about to get killed when suddenly Asana
saves his life and dies the game's
Creator then tries to murder a
heartbroken Kirito but his Plucky
attitude and spirit refuses to die and
he takes Commander stud face down with
him and they then disappear suddenly
Kirito wakes up in the middle of nowhere
and sees Asuna alive and well along with
Commander stud face and they see his
true identity for the first time he
politely introduces himself as kayaba
and reveals that these two have actually
won the game meaning that soon the
entire world world of Sword Art Online
will shut itself down forever logging
out the remaining players left alive and
allowing them to return to the real
world kayaba then disappears and Asuna
finds out Kirito's real name and she
tells him to come find her when they
wake up Suddenly Kirito known in the
real world as kasato wakes up and he
realizes that he's now back in the real
world weak and muscle-less kasato slowly
walks out of the hospital determined to
find his Bay once again proving that
when it comes to Young Love they will do
nothing to find their Bay hey guys thank
you so much for watching the video leave
a comment down below let us know what
you like about it and what you didn't
like about it and as always don't forget
to like And subscribe